elles ont été dérobés en
1892 lors de la mise à sac du palais
dabo mais au bénin par les troupes
coloniales françaises 26 avr s'apprête à
quitter le musée du quai branly devant
lequel nous nous trouvons pourra
rejoindre leur terre natale
cette restitution c'est plus qu'une
restitution c'est tout un programme de
coopération qui doit permettre de
renforcer nos liens de créer de
nouvelles opportunités des changes de
rencontres de projets toute jeunesse a
besoin de s'approprier l'histoire de son
pays pour mieux bâtir son futur
cette collection constitue une part
indéniable de l'identité culturelle et
cultuelle de notre pays emmanuel macron
poser un acte de justice mémorielle qui
vous fait entrer dans l'histoire des
relations de nos deux pays je vous
remercie un retour au bercail promis par
emmanuel macron est permis par une loi
votée fin 2020 et pour cause les biens
patrimoniaux conservé par les musées de
france sont inaliénables et
imprescriptibles
à l'origine de cette restitution le
rapport savoie sarr du nom de deux
universitaires elles ont posé les jalons
pour une restitution à l'afrique
d'oeuvres d'art transféré pendant la
colonisation
qui aurait pu imaginer il y a quatre ans
la restitution des pièces les plus
prestigieuses les plus belles les plus
connus du bénin personnes comme la chute
du mur de berlin il y aura un avant et
un après ce retour des oeuvres pillé par
l'armée française stéphane martin ancien
directeur du musée du quai branly a
toujours refusé le terme de restitution
il préfère parler de circulation de
partage un partage passant par des prêts
des dépôts et un certain nombre de
transferts de propriété
d'après de nombreux experts 85 à 90 % du
patrimoine africain serait hors du
continent au moins 90 mille objets d'art
d'afrique subsaharienne sont dans les
collections publiques françaises
soixante dix mille d'entre elles sont
conservées au quai branly dans 46 mille
sont arrivés durant la période coloniale
un travail de recherche a été entrepris
par ce musée pour identifier dans ses
collections les objets qui ont été
acquis de manière
je cite problématique cela consiste à
faire un travail quasi exhaustif sur les
300 mille oeuvres du musée pour
identifier celles qui auraient été
prises de manière violente sans le
consentement des propriétaires par des
prises de guerre ou par des coercition
de l'administration coloniale dé
restitution d'oeuvres que certains
marchands d'art dont bernard dulon
qualifie ch de néocolonialisme c'est une
hypocrisie totale on a pillé le
continent africain depuis mille ans
avant jésus-christ on continue de le
faire et on voudrait nous faire croire
qu'en rendant trois masques et 4 fétiche
on va se dédouaner c'est un peu délicat
je pense que la restitution est un
problème uniquement politiques mises en
avant par le gouvernement français qui
peut encore résister à l'invasion
chinoise en donnant quelques objets que
les chinois n'ont pas mais c'est très
clairement du néocolonialisme quoi qu'il
en soit ces 26 oeuvres béninoise devrait
être accueillie par le musée
international de la mémoire à ouidah
certainement les premières de plusieurs
autres